je sais qu'ils vont me fait penser au
sénat qui vous savez cette chanteuse
dans le jorat ben également célébrée
n'avait pas du tout changé qu'est ce que
vous voulez à la fin un concert prêt dès
lors à aujourd'hui à l'usiné hier sur
les scènes auprès des plus grands comme
abba et cliff richard
qu'est ce qui est arrivé pourquoi sa
tatie restants
jean m'a dit que vous travaillez avec
lui l usine j'y croyais pas tony john
rahway barre après vous a laissé tomber
un et puis après ça a été bouffé jugera
que je vais devenir ma nature de laura
je m'occupais de toi tu va redevenir une
vedette
combien le demande après 500 euros ça
marche il va falloir que je fasse à la
costume de tels faits coiffeur comme
pâques ça va coûter un bras et ton
nouveau manager pouvoir assumer tout ça
il sait pas que je suis ici je peux te
donner un coup de main si tu es sans
contrepartie
c'est très bien que tu étais le voir
sans le dire j'étais vendu à lui
je sais comment elle appelle les femmes
canton
et puis tout
mais si tu m'avais pas connu tu sois
encore en train de faire pour renée
martel maire
le besoin de beaucoup d'amour